[Music]
all right so earlier today sleepy creepy
crazy uncle Joe Biden was asked how he
would potentially handle President Trump
on the debate stage here's what he said
he starts making fun of your age your
mental state starts going after you in a
way is that this is I mean come on
Donald come on man how many pushups you
wanna do here pal you know I'm jokingly
you know come on run with me man come on
Donnell come on man how many pushups can
you do well Joe the president's busy
cleaning up the mess you left I'll take
you up on the challenge you name the
time and place I'm ready I don't even
need to practice I train every day all
right tell me where when that's all the
time we have left will never be the
destroy hate media mob let not your
heart be troubled laura ingraham you can
probably do more push-ups than both of
us probably both presidents watching so
you probably don't say let me see how
many I can do I could I could do more
push-ups than either Biden or him but
that's not really a big I mean they have
a few years on me at least but let me
tell you Hannity it always comes down to
that for guys doesn't it he's gonna show
he's still got it and he's still a
virile strong Joe intellect has no
energy show his own team knows that any
second he's gonna say another dumb thing
and he will well I don't know if that's
gonna distinguish them in this field